[Música]
fue uno de los desfiles más bonitos de
ricardo absolutamente une los hombres
las mujeres era simplemente divina
sí
[Música]
fue su espectáculo 111 en 20 años de
carrera tras graduarse en la central
saint martins de londres en 1999
trabajar con coca pan y nike y puma y
luego dirigir givenchy couture parís el
diseñador italiano riccardo tisci tomó
las riendas de la venerable casa
británica burberry en 2018 para esta
colección mixta de moda masculina y
prêt-à-porter femenino invierno 2022 ha
elegido como siempre un marco
excepcional una iglesia
para mí hoy en día la religión es algo
muy importante pero no me malinterpretes
ariane yo no significa sólo ser católico
o budista
religión consiste en que cada uno de
nosotros tenga la esperanza del mundo
mejor y estas mujeres hermosas enérgicas
poderosas pero correctas caminando como
aristócratas y rebeldes sobre las mesas
y todo el mundo elevando la mirada para
verlas y ver la ropa pero con respeto
eso era muy
reporter este es el problema de
cualquier mente creativa designada para
la dirección artística de una gran marca
como mantener el adn los códigos de una
marca y al mismo tiempo modernizar los
ricardo ticio ha optado por la
desestructuración en todos los sentidos
de la palabra
la especialidad de barber y siempre ha
sido la ropa exterior pero lo he
superado la identidad británica lo que
significa inglaterra para alguien de
europa
la noche de la fiesta
londres se rebosa de estas celebraciones
siempre que es posible organizamos
cócteles fiestas
pero al mismo tiempo existe la
aristocracia de sangre azul y la
rebelión
todo esto es inglaterra
la identidad británica eso es lo que
quería representar nuestra colección
así que hice vestidos de noche de
algodón gabardina escuchado en resumidas
cuentas mezcle dos cosas la rebelión y
la aristocracia en este sentido barberá
es un símbolo perfecto en este país
riccardo tisci nació en 1974 en el sur
de italia en taranto una ciudad
portuaria popular y contaminada a los 4
años perdió a su padre fue criado por su
madre y sus ocho hermanas de
hoy como mis 20 años de experiencia
puedo expresarme como un adulto cuando
empecé en givenchy por ejemplo recuerdo
que la gente no mente en mali a porque
no había inventado nada de nuevos además
no era mi funciona en aquella época todo
era glamuroso llevé la calle a la alta
costura la alta costura
se desarrolla a la alta costura en el
cerebro de un niño que siempre sueña con
progresar con triunfar un soñador
para el pasaporte fui el primero voy a
decir el primero en la historia de la
moda pero si el primero que volvió a
poner en primer plano la ropa casual
cuando estuve en givenchy y empecé a
tener éxito no olvides de donde venía
creciendo una vivienda de interés social
vengo de una familia muy pobre así que
para mí era muy importante hacer
suéteres camisetas tenis bolsos
cualquier cosa que la generación más
joven pudiera comprar
no importa a la gente le gusta usar
estas expresiones en la generación joven
eso no me gusta intento construir es una
colección democrática y popular
trabajo para todos para todos los tipos
de cuerpo creencias mentalidades y
etnias y para poder compartir este sueño
con todos sin excluir a nadie para mí
esto es lo más importante en esta
colección es muy fuerte
así que para responder a su pregunta
dziwisz mi infancia es una gran fuente
de inspiración porque nunca olvidaré de
donde vengo también él se inspira en su
infancia cuando vivía en el distrito de
las prostitutas en tokio no entendía por
qué siempre llevaban tacones de aguja
en yohji yamamoto si anda sin tacones se
les construye y se mezclan siglos y
telas
[Música]
a leyes
simplemente empecé a esta colección
mezclando tejidos vaqueros con
materiales de alta costura del siglo 18
permanezcamos en el ambiente de los
grandes salones parisinos en coche en el
siglo pasado este mítico lugar acogió
entre otras las presentaciones de exxon
long con cristal coser desarrolla cierto
concepto de la elegancia urbana
y
un deseo de retomar esta idea de la alta
costura pero con poesía con comodidad
con brocados excepcionales con suéteres
tejidos de punto cachemira o lana
algo envolvente algo reconfortante y
también un mensaje optimista que fue
transmitido por todos estos hermosos
jóvenes que vienen de todo el mundo y
que están juntos fue hermoso
en londres y parís las colecciones de
prêt-à-porter actualizan constantemente
los clásicos pero sin olvidar un
elemento importante sin el cual la moda
ya no existiría la diversidad